oops hold on one
second there we go hello can you hear me
what's up man are you
Muslim yep I just think my question to
you is just that I think it's much more
reasonable to believe if of course one
one who puts faith in this scripture to
believe that um Jesus who died who uh
who was UN alive was rather a p a human
a Muslim rather than being a God just
like logically speaking I think it's
more reasonable to believe one side of
the story than
another all right what's the what's the
logic there break it down for me I in my
view under my view God is eternal he's
not begotten or begot he can't like
there's no dying there's no there's no
him he's he's the one and only so him on
being on alive just doesn't sound
probable with my it's not compatible
with what I believe
okay I see
um if if Allah wanted to could he take
on human
form first of all I under under Muslim
view I think that itself is like a
disrespect first of all right but like
it's like lowering himself we don't even
talk like that but I mean since I
brought logic and I think I can respect
that question I mean logically speaking
I would say that because if if you
believe he he is someone that can do
anything I don't see a limitation for
him to do so yes beautiful he can he can
that's what you're asking it's logically
possible however however my concern is
that hence my name right ironically that
it's like to me it sounds like you
asking me can God create a rock that's
so heavy that he cannot lift himself
that's notal
self sorry that's a logical
contradiction so that wouldn't be yeah
it's a self it's a self-contradictory
statement right but more importantly
taking on a human form is not a
self-contradictory St no but but but
when you ask me like an old like a being
like God of Allah can make himself a
mere mortal finite human nobody said M
mortal nobody said mere mortal finite
what does it mean to be a human well
what you're well your question should be
what does it mean for God to take on
human flesh so ask me a question can God
be a human
so well I asked specifically can God
take on human form and walks amongst us
and so you said logically yes he can
right now nobody's saying that if God
were to take on human form that he is a
mere human obviously not he's God as
well what does it mean to be human to
you you have all the human
properties can humans die yes you can
you can die as human yeah I don't
yeah what does it mean to
die uh well good question it is where
one's existence is over no because when
you die here do you cease to exist or do
you just go to another
realm true but the but like you do lose
like you you do lose oneself right and I
don't think God is can do that you don't
lose you don't lose yourself when you
when you die you're you're going to be
you're going to face God on Judgment Day
right so you still exist and you still
have your sense of self and you still
are guilty for the things you've done
and you still have the rewards for the
things you've done good so can an all
powerful thing die well we let's
identify what death is first so can we
agree that death is not the ceasing of
existence but simply just it's a
separation from Body and
Soul yeah I can I can yeah I agree with
that okay so if so since we know now
what death is it's just a separation
from Body and Soul right soul is just
move into a different realm so if God
were to take on human
flesh he could die pertaining to that
human flesh he could separate his soul
from that body it doesn't mean he ceases
to exist okay there okay actually yeah I
see what you're saying and I I do I
would say that that is coherent however
I don't think inductively speaking
that's reasonable because I think that
there like again as again when I
subjectively think I think the the
intent behind
Jesus uh being a pro like being
God like my question is why there it is
there it is it's the why so
right and I think understanding the why
would also help understand the action
you know that he took but the but first
I just wanted to solidify that we can
both agree that it is it is logical and
it is sound that God if he wanted to
could take on human form and pertaining
to that human form experience death
separation from Soul and body not
meaning that he ceases to exist or
anything like that but that's just what
what he can do logically right now the
question is why in the world would he do
that in the first place why
would the holy all powerful um just God
lower himself and lower his majesty to
the form of a human and experience death
like humans do why in the world without
running into an
absurdity right without running into an
absurdity and here's the quick answer
the quick answer is love that's the
quick answer well of course we're gonna
elaborate on that right of course I I a
Just Gonna Leave You there I ain't just
gonna leave you there all
right that's why I said the quick answer
the quick answer is love now to
elaborate on what this is this love that
he
demonstrates is that the Bible says now
remember God is just he's holy he's
perfect okay so with his Justice and his
Holiness he has a standard of living he
has a standard that we are as his
creation as his servants supposed to
uphold to but we fail at the standard we
fall short of the standard right which
is perfection and Holiness now because
he's holy and he's just he can't just
allow us to just go unpunished right
just like somebody in a a judge in a
court room if you robbed a bank he can't
just let you go even if you are sorry
right exactly so you have to be punished
for your crime or for your sin now okay
the Bible says that the Wage of Sin the
price of sin against God is death it's
Eternal separation from God however he
loves us right he loves us and he's
merciful um so and he doesn't want us to
be separated from him so what does he do
he offers away where Justice can be
served sin can be punished right where
doesn't just get swept under the rug
while at the same time his mercy and his
grace can be handed out and that's
through him taking on the form of man
representing
Mankind and paying the price for for our
sin
himself hey man that's a great narrative
right but personally it doesn't sit well
with me I think it's very unnecessary
number one second I think it's a dis
again I'm sorry it's maybe this the
Muslim and me I think it's very
disrespectful behalf of God talking
about taking a form as the sinful beings
as we
are um third I think it's a very bad
message to humans to being un alived um
as a good thing because he as an all
powerful being under your view who
wanted to let's say uphold the sins from
humans could have chosen to do otherwise
but yet he chooses to get unived it just
sounds like in very kind of chosen to do
otherwise what do you mean by could have
chosen to do otherwise chosen like he
could have chosen to uplift our sins for
us by doing anything else than human and
getting unive like what I don't know
snapping his fingers oh so so Bas so
basically sweeping sin under the rug
again because remember we eliminated
that we showed the necessity of it the
necessity is is his Justice and his
Holiness he
cannot yeah so he he can't let sin go
unpunished because he's holy and just
okay he could have toen that care of but
what was the second reason you said the
attribute of him being taking human form
I missed it what you said there was two
reasonable there are two reasons to
believe that him it's it would make
sense why he took the form of of a man
being Jesus Christ is for love to being
just and something else he could have
been just it's his love and his Justice
it's his love and his Holiness his
Justice yeah but he again actually he
could he could have showed his sign of
love again without being a human and
getting un
alive but how how how how what what's
the what's the how can he appease his
Justice by punishing sin because it has
to be dealt with he can't just let it go
it'll be against his nature to let sin
just ride so how can he appease his
Justice and punish sin while also not us
not being the bearers of his
punishment am I all knowing no you're
not so God is all knowing so again yes
and my my qu my the answer is there was
there is no way this was the way in the
interesting interesting okay so
interesting what what i' propose to you
is that this I think I want to retract
from my original statement that you
asking me could God have turn U become
human logically speaking yes but now the
implication that you would run into is
the Big G small G if God himself decided
to to become to to transition into a
human then where was then God governing
where did he then where did Big G end up
going how that doesn't make sense
because he's God he's not not he's not
not God anymore he doesn't cease to be
God so he can take on human form and
walks amongst us while also at the same
time still sustain the
universe you get what I'm saying he's
God okay okay do you believe go I have a
question do you believe God can make
atheism
true no that's a logical contradiction
right right okay so God can't do
illogical things despite of him being
all powerful and what I'm trying to
prove is that that him becoming human is
illogical how you got you got know that
I I guess right I mean I'm not equipped
I'm not because remember we we just we
already we already agreed
that said I was trying to R I was trying
to retract from that I just don't think
it would make sense for now you know God
forbid Allah or God taking human form
then as I said then you said Big G yeah
all all you're all you're saying is that
it wouldn't make sense for him to do it
you're not saying that it doesn't make
sense that he can do it
so you're you're talking about intent
versus ability did Jesus have to eat he
he he he ate he's a human he got hungry
you know pertaining to his human nature
he to but if he wanted to he could hold
up if he wanted to he could have
sustained himself if he wanted to but he
did no so exactly I'm saying I'm talking
about under your view he had to eat so
when he ate what did he have to then re
did he then have to use the restroom in
order to convert let me let me give you
the full the full
explanation Jesus he limited and humbled
himself to human
limitations so he was human in every way
that we were right he got hungry he
slept he uh you know used the bathroom
that's not God bro that that it's human
it's Humanity he takes on a human nature
human it's you and I but the person okay
so if he's able to do this humble
himself to human limitations walk
amongst us as a human live amongst us as
humans do that doesn't change the fact
that he himself is God who is doing this
who has decided to take on a human form
take on a human nature and walk amongst
us as a human God logic you keep saying
he had to Humble himself to walk human
are you saying that he has the need to
become human in order to know how it
feels like being human creator of all
you're you're missing what I said I
never said I never please no cussing on
the stage but I never I never said that
he had to do this I said this is what he
did I never said he needed to do this
this is just what he did okay so he
didn't need to do it and then you at the
same time you are that's what I'm saying
I think it's more rational to just
believe that Jesus was not a God but
you're not you're not showing you're not
showing me why this is not rational
because you're saying okay first of all
you just said that he didn't need to but
he just did it now if didn't need to
then why again should I believe that
because we needed you miss it again we
needed him to do it he did it for us not
for himself Paradox are you
listening you said we needed him as
humans he didn't yes so are you
listening to my answer because I I need
you to pay attention to what I'm saying
because I feel like I'm repeating it now
pay attention to what I'm saying I said
this in the beginning remember what was
what was my quick answer when you asked
why would he do this in the exactly love
not because he needs this it's because
we needed him to do this we were under
condemnation we sinned against him and
we were under his wrath we needed a
repres we're s right now we don't we sin
now and you need a savior see the
difference between you and I I have a
savior you don't you're still under
condemnation because you don't you
haven't accepted his gift of Grace so
right now you'll be under his again we
don't have a lord and savior quote
unquote we have a merciful just being
that is going to take care of things in
the day of judgment here's my question
is it just to let sin sweep under the
rug if long it is taken care of the day
of judgment
wait I have a question for you pause
pause bro just pause okay go
ahead is it just to let sin get swept
under the
rug of course not okay so in your
Paradigm since Allah is this has all
this Mercy what does he do with your
does he punish you for your sin yes
really what happens to you as a Muslim J
so so you go to hell as a
Muslim yes temporar but we're promised
as a Muslim that we'll all be given the
gift one day to reach Paradise if we
have given the kma and believe in our
Allah just just I just want you to sit
on what you just said so that everybody
realizes what you just said as a as a
Muslim and a believer
you as a Muslim will go to hell is that
correct of course
temporarily and see no not all of us not
all of us who wait who's not gonna go
first of all it's it's stated in our
scripture that as a finite human
understanding that even have I have no
one to speak behalf I don't know if you
will go to heaven or hell just because
you're a Christian don't mean God will
throw you to hell right God is the true
one to know who goes to hell in heaven
and that being said one thing that he
promises that every Muslim eternally
will reach Paradise after obtaining the
sins that they have caused in planet
Earth will every Muslim go to
hell no okay so there are some Muslims
that will go unpunished for the sins
that they've Comm yes from dying from
being unived sorry dying during the
month of Ramadan people who have died as
children people who have died without
understanding of what it meant there's
many reasons why one can go to paradise
directly as a Muslim okay but just
because going
to some Muslim so some Muslims who have
died during Ramadan are going to go
straight to heaven without their sins
being dealt with correct no they're have
already been dealt
with the the the because the fact that
they're Muslims who had been you know
fasting I have a great answer for you
and the same reason why I would like you
to answer what I was trying to ask you
earlier the same reason how under your
view someone can be doing some atrocious
things that I don't even want to say but
then if he builds a relationship with
Jesus Christ and now all of a sudden all
of his sins have been gone as if he was
never that's not that's not what that's
not what gets rid of your sins Paradox
see do you think that's just Paradox
please do not strongman my position see
when you when you want when you want to
make when you want to make an argument
Paradox you want to make an argument
based on someone's actual position
instead of a straw man a
misrepresentation right yeah all right
very good so what we believe is that
Jesus Took on the punishment for our
sins he was crucified whipped and
pierced was for our sins but I that's
what I'm talk I know you should have
this is my point this is my
point the Jesus Took the punishment and
was bruised for our iniquities for our
sins so a punishment was dealt out when
it comes to you as a Muslim you're
saying that these people who died during
Ramadan nobody was nobody was punished
for their sins so how is the sin dealt
with it's just swept under the
rug which we agree not track if you were
tracking well if you were tracking I had
asked you the question when you said
that the reason why it's reasonable for
Jesus being crucified is because of the
sins that had to be dealt with that we
needed him you said he didn't need to we
needed him and then I said don't we need
him right now don't people sin at the
current in present day which is why you
need a savior right and then I responded
with right that we don't need a savior
to come down and get un alived we will
all be dealt with at the day of judgment
no you won't though you just said that
there's a selection of you that won't be
dealt with on the day of judgment the
ones that God knows that doesn't need to
oh okay stop right there does every
Muslim sin in their lifetime the ones
who actually live a life do they sin I'm
not talking about people
honest I'd be dishonest if I'd say no
but well actually I can say yes a if if
a Muslim child I'm talking about a child
dude I'm not talking about a child I'm
talking about adults yes they yes we all
commit sin all right every Muslim
commits sin now for these Muslims who
have lived their life and committed sins
in their lifetime they die during
fasting of
Ramadan do they get punished for their
sin on Judgment Day
their sin their sins have been
replenished
how by fasting and gr by doing what God
asked you see what I'm saying it's swept
under the rug there's no punishment
dealt out that's your that's your
perception that's no that's no that's
just what it is I don't get look it's
it's like this hey man um I I I have
sinned I've stolen or whatever it is
I've lied I've committed adultery
whatever it is um but I was fasting
during Ramadan and so now me fasting
during
Ramadan takes away or covers what I did
or I get to get into heaven because of
SCH refuse some Scholars refuse some
shakes don't agree with that narrative
but this is your I I don't care what
others disagree I'm talking about you
you Paradox you yourself you yourself
you believe that a person who dies in
Ramadan gets their sin swept under I was
giving okay bro I was giving you an
example when you had asked are does
every Muslim go to hell I had said some
Muslims for external reasons might not
go to hell for people who have died as a
young age people who God knows that
never got the word of Allah right people
who die during special again and you
know there are reasons that Muslims
canot go to hell but just because Muslim
is going to hell for his sins that
because he's a merciful just God he will
then promise all Muslims who believes in
Allah and Muhammad peace upon him to one
day receive Paradise that's it okay so
again so we don't need a lord and savior
okay so again your sin gets swept under
the rug and it's not dealt with for
certain select few of you right I can
say the same thing that about you no you
can't because no you can't you you you
want to know why you can't and and by
the way this two ququ doesn't work this
is why you can't who was punished for my
sins
according to my belief but you didn't he
Jesus Christ no one no one and see now
you're being dishonest because you know
why and been listen I'm not because
Jesus Jesus Christ didn't in our era I'm
I'm not asking about you about your
belief you said according to me you said
you can say the same about me just be
honest according to under your view I
guess okay so under my belief there has
been somebody took the punishment for my
sin right but can you substantiate that
can you can you wait before you before
you Shuffle away answer the question
somebody in my Paradigm died for my sins
correct yes thank you so in my Paradigm
I'm not getting off scottf free the sin
was dealt with and was punished through
Christ now for you in your Paradigm with
for those select few
who die during
Ramadan how are their sins
punished or do they go
unpunished my God I guess at this point
I just have I I I don't know is right I
I I don't know the the logic behind of
what is the cause of Muslims I don't
even know if all Muslims who die during
Ramadan I just heard which is not a good
thing to talk behalf of that could end
up going to heaven that's all I heard I
didn't even I didn't read that from
scripture and I don't claim things upon
that I don't get from my scripture okay
but more importantly uh a question I
have for you you're not about to move
past that just now now what you just
said was extremely important because now
it sounds like you kind of backtracked
away from that to now it's you don't
know which which which which by the way
Paradox it's it's okay like you know
there's no problem with that as long as
we can admit that right however let's
let's still deal with the implications
of that because that's what you was
appealing to to say see we don't need a
savior my question is is that just is
Allah just if he allow certain people to
make it into heaven without punishing
their sins just because they died during
Ramadan again okay he doesn't have a
reason to punish those that don't he
doesn't he not going to punish those
that doesn't have a reason to be
punished is is is sinning is sinning a
reason to be
punished if you sin against Allah do you
have a reason to be
punished not all sins and there if I ask
for forg see not being not all sins if I
ask for forgiveness I won't be punished
for it exactly and there it is if you
ask for forgiveness you don't need to be
punished cuz what is all gonna do just
one one one
second second one second I'm get my prop
hold on one second okay just meet up
real quick I promise you okay this is
what our GNA do ladies and gentlemen
bro
yo what is going on
yo come
back this right
here this what all I was going to do
ladies and
gents all you
do is ask for
[Music]
forgiveness one
second oh you got to
do clean that room boy is ask that's
what that's what all's
doing man just ask for forgiveness stuck
for the LI yo just go ahead it's all
right Allah I got you just goad ask for
forgiv just say yourself clown you're a
clown you are a clown just say you're
sorry Paradox you're good you are a
clown bro anyway if you can come back
and don't worry about it all you got to
do is say sorry Allah don't worry about
it bro you're being a again log again
come back again not all sins are
permissible to about sweetheart right
are you listen don't worry about
sweetheart Allah's
got not all sins are
forgivable right again so so logic there
are there are Cate atories right there's
a threshold of your sins we don't
believe like you guys again any sin can
be saved from the Lord and Savior
there's a there are unforgivable sins sh
uh Shing is unforgivable disrespectful
to your parents is not forgivable right
certain aspects are can't be forgived
and so I just think that you don't again
you're just kind of conflating the two
ideas to like you know this this is what
we're talking about Paradox look I'm
talking about all those other examples
of things that are not forgivable I'm
talking about the specific times that
you admit that all you got to do is ask
Allah for forgiveness and he'll forgive
you God no strings
attached if you let me finish this if
you can answer please let me finish this
ask you a question okay this is why this
matters man remember in the beginning of
this in the beginning we
said if a judge were to just let you go
because you said sorry after you broke
the law and he just lets you go
unpunished is he just and you said no
he's not just so
similarly even more so if the judge of
the heavens and the Earth just lets you
say sorry and just sweeps your sin under
the rug he's an unjust judge maybe he's
merciful sure I can grant that there's
some mercy there but he's not just and
that's where Allah is insufficient so
let's talk about it let's talk about it
yes I do understand in Islam there are
99 attributes that God has being just as
one of them but let's talk about the
just I'm not I'm not running away but
listen hold up hold up so you're giving
an example of a judge who is making a
decision right you are not the judge
it's Allah let if you can provide me a
reason I'm G to ask you a question and
if you can answer it then then I'll
admit I'll accept it I have a question
right let's say again let's again not
all things are in legality first of all
I don't think legality is morality there
are things that are right or wrong
without judges right for instance a
school your work environment your
parents right your family your love life
there's right so now if in in these
settings for instance a child who right
I listen let me give you an example of
when you can ask for forgiveness it'll
be forgiven and if you don't think
that's just please tell me what why so
let's say I know and I'm a very well
aware that I cannot eat pork I know this
for a fact that I am not supposed to be
eating pork it's not under the uh it's
it's it's not condoned and I go to I go
to an event and guess what they're
giving food and uh you know for we're
giving food to people who have graduated
and I'm eating food and you know people
made it I'm acknowledging it I'm being
respectful I eat the food and then later
I learned that a friend says yo uh
Paradox did you eat this I'm like yeah
oh it had pork inside I'd be like oh
well I didn't know that right yes I have
quote unquote qu done something wrong
without knowing so if then I decide to
pray to God and ask for forgiveness Ya
Allah I did not know that I have eaten
pork please forgive me now please tell
me why would he not be just for
forgiving someone who did not know about
it please explain um would Allah punish
you for eating that pork when you did it
unknowingly would he punish you for that
no if again if I again only got and by
the way and I mean to tell you another
extent right not all not all for not all
forgiveness are guaranteed to be forgiv
no worry that's that's a that's a
different topic answer this if you eat
the pork if you eat pork without knowing
it KN and let's let's say it was never
brought to your attention would Allah
punish you for
that interesting good question
um uh I mean that's a lot to know but I
I I won't have a reason to believe that
he would because believe he's old knows
so that would mean that if you did it
unknowingly then it's not a sin then sin
has has int behind uh interesting no
interest that's just about interesting
way to put it so then I just say then
the statement that I can just say no to
you when you first ask me can God
forgive the sins that you have committed
then I just say no because and those are
not sins I guess under your definition
so you're saying eating pork is not a
sin knowing or un can can you can you
break that down please yeah yeah if
you're if you're saying that what I had
originally considered a sin for God to
forgive without me pay being punished
right then I just say no I I cannot be
forgived for my my sins without being
punished if you're not classifying me
eating pork as a sin unknowingly yes
then yes does that make sense because I
so so no the qu the answer to your
question will God forgive my sins
without Punishment No he would
not
okay so but there are some people you
said earlier that he for because you
seems like you you didn't even consider
those sins the reason why I was saying
these things is that no I I no it's what
it's what you don't know you're not
you're not held accountable for
something you ignorance exactly
something that's understand so you
didn't you didn't sin if you yeah if you
don't have if you have lack of
understanding or if you're just ignorant
of something we're talking about people
who have clearly s and are guilty like
you're not guilty for eating pork
unknowingly you're not guilty we're
talking about people who are guilty
you're the sins that you're guilty
for that's what we're talking about and
you're saying you can just ask God for
forgiv Allah for forgiveness nope nope
that's not what I was saying then that's
what I'm saying so no that's not what I
was saying then if if you don't think
that there people are should be deemed
guilty okay we still and Islam by the
way that's why we don't again it's a
very beautiful thing we ask for
forgiveness every single day is because
we understand that we're sinful beings
we do bad things without knowing I don't
care how many times a day you ask for
forgiveness
what does Allah do about your about your
sin that you're asking forgiveness for
what does he do about it that's for him
to know that's for him to know no no no
this is for you to know as well cuz
you're a Muslim you're follow you're
following this this God right so you
need to know what happens you need to
know how am I how am I redeemed from my
from my so there's two scenarios hold on
let me land let me land my I have my
answer Jesus Paid it for me what's your
answer
okay before I give you a Critic before I
give you an internal critique of your
view boy am I waiting but to answer your
question I have two I have two scen I
have two scenarios right what does he do
if I ask for forgiveness and he forgives
then great out of my ignorance and if he
doesn't forgive me I shall pay it a day
of judgment very simple we will go to
hell we will go to Janam and do what we
did re our and you said that there are
some for who Allah forgives without
punishing them
you said that earlier is that no longer
the case so we okay why do you believe
exactly we punishment is not the only
way to justify something so okay how is
sin paid for in Islam for those who he
does not punish for their sin how is it
how is it
reconciled to giving them hardship in
this on this Earth giving them hardship
on this Earth guys hardship on this
Earth is the reconciliation of
your y That's we and HJ is also another
thing so so let me ask you you do you H
right stop stop there stop there do you
think that uh a a a baby and you know
being sick with cancer or and disease
and stuff like that that that's hardship
in this life of course is that them
reconciling their sins of course so
babies have sins that they need to have
reconciled depends on the age of the
child
babies no babies don't again uh we don't
yeah babies don't have sin babies go to
heaven yes so when babies are having
hardship in this life are they are there
do they are they is it because they have
sins that are being
reconciled well you believe that wait
don't you believe all humans are born
with sins no I believe we're born into
sin but this is my par this is we're
talking about Shores right now you need
to justify that we all believe that
human are sinful by Nature so is a baby
guilty of sin by definition yes a baby's
guilty of sin in Islam is he a if he's a
human baby then yes if he's a human baby
what Angel Baby a jin baby right so it's
a human baby then yes right they other
animals and he is born in sinful nature
he or she so I'm getting other Muslims
that are saying no no way but I mean you
know this this is your view so bab I
like them to tell me then why it's
Justified if they think that exactly
yeah Muslims come on up and help them
out but more importantly right so so yes
so there are ways of re Recon like being
able to utilize these things of course
always would you say that it's unjustice
for Allah to send a baby to
hell would it be unjust to send a baby
to hell of course but you said that they
are sinful it wouldn't be unjust to send
them to hell if they if they have sin
yeah but they never had time to again
they never had time to redeem themselves
there's an age of time where God kills
so what if they are born guilty then
it's not unjustice send them to
hell no no no so there's a difference
right there's a difference committing a
sin and there's a difference being
sinful nature having a sinful nature
right acting upon this is where
difference I know I know so this this is
why see now you're you're you're kind of
changing what you were saying when I
asked you about the baby in the first
place when a baby is going through
hardships right sickness and disease and
health problems or whatever in this life
hardships in this life
is it because they the babies have sin
that is now being reconciled with Allah
due to their
hardships okay so I see what you're
doing now hardship is not only dependent
on reconcil like something that to be
able to reconcile with there are other
reasons that hardship does not always
equate to being reconciled right there
can be other reasons too of course
that's why sh murderers are also paid
right they're they're going to be
they're going to be punished for causing
unnecessary pain so yeah how is
theproduct so then how can you even say
that if a person who dies in Ramadan uh
had hardships in their life that that's
what made that's what reconciled the sin
in their life how how can you say that
where where where where does even the
Quran say that hardships reconcile sin
in your life I know that's exactly what
I gonna say now all right I'm you're
making me speak rather asking me or
telling me to explain a contradiction or
something doesn't sense you're you're
asking to speak behalf of God and I'm
just going to tell you right there's a
threshold and criteria of thing right
depends on what sins they've committed
did they lie to their Butler or did they
hurt someone did they blew up a God
forbid of mush you know breaking
someone's heart in Islam is equivalent
to breaking a mhed right so I don't know
what sins they've they've committed for
me to say that it depends on the person
it depends on God's understanding of
that person I'm no one to answer for
that for to you my brother so this this
is what I'm saying Paradox this is my
entire point with this my entire Point
bro is that we have an explanation and a
reason for our salvation and how God's
justice and mercy and love is
demonstrated you ask question you as a
hold on dude relax you as a Muslim you
don't and every which way which don't
accept it no it's not that I brother
there's nothing for me to accept you
there
no every time no you like it every every
time you try to give an answer and I and
I you know gave you the started sleep
room I gave you I gave you the
implications I gave you the implications
of what you were saying you then
retracted every single time you've
retracted every time that we came to the
conclusion of what because again there's
too much I'm a moral again yes I I will
say that you're right okay for the sake
of the argument if you want to say I had
to go back to explain things to you read
the Quran by the way in in transl but
you haven't explained anything look at
this point where we are in this
conversation we're we're at we're at
point zero there is no explanation for
how sin is dealt with with for you as a
Muslim for those people day of Jud day
of judgment all right so what determines
for a person who dies on in Ramadan what
happens with them on the day of judgment
whether they go to Hell or Heaven
God will know so no answer not me God
knows I don't no one knows so no answer
then God the answer is God so no
answer what are you asking me the day of
Des what happens to someone fasted okay
I can tell you it depends on their
intentions right so I don't know I'm not
God it depends on their intentions of
fasting it depends on what they've done
God knows all of this information so
he'll know if he he because he's all
just he will know if they should go go
to paradise or hell that's it okay let's
let's let's see we have to continue to
explore that God decides whether what
they've done in their life is worthy of
them going to hell or them going to
heaven got it correct so he'll make the
ultimate decision what like when it when
when he's making the decision on a
person who's going to heaven what is
that based on because this same person
has good okay his deeds his Works he's
done good he's done things that makes
him deserving of heaven but the same
person who he's deeming is worthy of
Heaven has sinned in his life so when
he's getting into heaven what is
happening with the sin how does his sin
get dealt
with it's like a weight like when you
skill something you put weight on one
side and if you put weight on another
and outbalances it outs it so Paradox I
like see this is why you're still here
because we're you're able to yeah why
you're still here so look let's let's so
there's a weight now there's a scale so
let me ask you this okay let's say I
have in my I'm 30 years old okay and
let's say wow for 28 years of my life 28
years of my life or let's say 29 29
years of my life right um thought you
were 24 oh you know thank you but for 29
years of my life I've continuously given
to
charity I've uh visited people in the
sick bed I visited people in prison I've
uh you know fought for the people who
don't really have a voice in the
political world okay right I've done all
these good right never committed a crime
never stolen never killed nobody never
done any of these things right but in my
30th year on my 30th birthday okay I
robbed a
bank okay now I get caught I'm in the
court they coming for you
yeah they coming for me exactly they
coming for me to go on I'll mute myself
I'm listening so wait don't mute
yourself it's okay so I I'm I'm in the
courtroom I'm caught I'm guilty and I
say to the judge judge yes you got me I
rob the bank that's me on that video
camera however judge this is the only
crime I've ever broken look at the first
29 years of my life I've you know tended
to the sick I've visited the poor I've
given to charity I've done all these
things that you know on a scale that
that's that way outweighs this one bad
thing I did with the judge let me go you
do understand that even first of all I
don't think it's equivalent to use
morals with legality and even to
entertain what you're saying you do
understand even in the legal world that
they do actually take and consider if
it's your first or second time that if I
a bank if I if I robbed a bank will the
judge let me go as that's my first crime
if it's a yes or no question of course
no that'd be that'd be absurd now what
if he did if he did would it be if he
did would it be just then I would again
if you I was going to get to there now
right now there are many factors that we
need to consider how much consequences
or harm that you committed to rob a bank
were there any casualties doesn't matter
you do depending on were you forced were
you I went in I it's armed robbery man I
went in there I'm saying exactly what
what was your ention you to steal money
my intention was to get the bag baby I
was getting the bag baby you will be
responsible for that you will be held
responsible for that but it's my only
crime I've ever committed the good
things I've done outweigh this one bad
right
yeah question false equivalence false
it's a perfect equivalence would the
judge be just if he let me go on the
basis that I've done more good than this
bad this than this one time I've
committed a crie I refuse I'm not a
judge don't you don't you do that don't
you do that don't you do don't you do
that I know it won't be okay for the
judge in in in in legality to let you go
yes I would disagree with the judge so
he would be unjust
right yes okay now let's let's let's put
this in perspective here all right this
Earthly judge would be unjust if he were
to uh let me go on the basis that I've
done more good in my life than bad he
would be unjust for letting me go that I
agree yeah I agree with you he that
would not be just which is why I said
even Muslims would go to hell okay butor
but wait no we're not we're not talking
about the Muslims that go to hell we're
talking about the ones that go to heaven
right and who still have sins but they
but God all lets him in heaven anyway
because of the scale now if the judge is
UN just now let me ask you this and I
think we we both know the answer to this
Allah would is supposed to be supposed
to be infinitely more just than a human
judge right of course of course so if a
judge on Earth can't even let you go to
you know for the sake of Justice because
of the good things you've done in your
life even though you're guilty of this
crime how much more is the just
judge right going to exact
Justice not based on because you've done
good but if you Jud much as God does the
judge also loves him much as God and man
you are on a row here does the judge
love him as much as God no no which is
why guess what which is why you need a
situation this guy connecting the
[__] my langage connecting the dots
right
this is why you need a situation Paradox
for where God is enacting his Justice he
doesn't sacrifices justice but also his
love is demonstrated as well so you need
God to be you need a sufficient
situation where God is both just and
loving at the same time allow me to ask
question allow me to ask a question now
okay I that's see the point I I I see
where you're going with it and I I want
better I'm asking for clarification CL
clarifying question okay now I see what
you're saying yeah there this is this
was your perfect time to assert that
okay so now my my my question to you I
trying to remember is now the love part
is great but please help me understand
how is it just for a a a being who had
been unived for the love of for the to
just to you know for the sins of humans
that you weren't uh there at that time
who is after born after Jesus was
crucified for allowing you guys to be
redemp redeemed uh Redemption for that
how is that why is that just okay so one
it's just because you have God right
controller of everything who is able to
make the Willing decision to and has the
ability right his life is infinitely
worth more more than anything which is
why his life is able to appease the the
wage that is owed when he gives his life
instead of us giving our lives he his
life satisfies it all so he has the
ability the power to take on the sins of
everyone past present and future and he
has the willingness to come in and pay
the fine for my crime similar to like
like so even in the courtroom same same
example there's a bail amount sometimes
for a crime right there's a bail amount
now if I don't have the money to pay the
bail amount someone can willfully come
in and slide that Court to that money to
the courtroom and say I got them don't
worry about it and I alternative yeah
yep so God what God does one he has the
ability and the power to take on the
sins of mankind past present and future
and he has the willingness to do it out
of love and so he comes into the
courtroom and he pays my fine okay I
have a question so I'm I'm right me and
everyone who is a Muslim right now okay
who have also who have committed sins
I've lied in the past right I've I've
I've lied to people I have not fasted I
didn't pray as much okay I do a lot of
things that are not good under iview so
I have a question so now now or even
someone who've done even more horrible
things and I have a question if I
convert to Christianity right now or
tomorrow or in the future anywhere
before I die I create a relationship I I
convert to Christianity I accept Jesus
Christ to be my Lord and Savior will I
be punished for the things that I've
done so if you're talking about your
Eternal sin and what you've done and
your eternal life is secure okay you cuz
Christ uned someone Christ uned someone
Christ has already taken the punish for
you if you are wild well well hey this
is what it is it's either you are are
are you know you got to take on God's
Wrath or you take you accept the gift of
Grace that he has Tak that he's given
you because he's taken the wrath upon
himself so that you don't subit if
sumler had
converted Christ after his [__]
excuse me after his action would you say
he would not have been punished what
what I'm saying is is that Christ took
on the punishment for everyone I just
answered you what are you what is wrong
with you I just answered you if shler if
shler wait paradox paradox paradox
paradox par par Paradox what are you not
hearing what are you not hearing I was
asking true or false what what what did
you not hear from my answer please I
didn't hear true or false all right here
it is again please Focus okay okay no
matter what you've done in your
past right
yeah right no matter what you've done in
your past Christ if you accept
Christ you accept his gift he paid the
price of your sin now what you do now as
the Bible says ABS yeah absolutely sin
is dealt with sin is dealt with Christ
came in and paid the
fine Christ came in and he paid the
price wait What wait I I'm curious wait
so Chris I'm wait I'm confused what are
you confused about please
please deal with what I just said yeah
yeah I'm I'm digesting it and I don't I
don't I didn't find any like I didn't
find any issue with that other than just
not sitting well with me and again
subjectively I don't think that's enough
for me to say that but I I'm just
curious so are any Christians punished
at any times after creating a building a
relationship with Jesus yeah there
there's there's things that we go
through in life that we put ourselves
through because of our decisions because
of the sins we commit or bad decisions
we make there's a result
of of what
happens okay don't you think this is my
last question to you to propose to
Christianity I will commend you again
you've aned everything well you had some
moments to be a little funny I don't
know what that was about but more
importantly this what we do here more
importantly what I more important what I
want to say is do you think do you think
don't you think that it's de
incentivized for humans to take
responsibilities of their moral actions
if you're giving them this message of
Lord and Savior uh having to redeem all
humans from what they do don't you think
that deifies people to to take
responsibility of their moral actions
can I can I answer you you know what let
me not me I'm sorry not can I answer you
I'm gonna let the Bible answer you is
that
okay oh that'd be that'd be even better
because the Bible the Bible literally
has your exact question that's literally
what your views are coming from so it'
be more precise how you answer it yeah
go ahead so watch this this is Romans
chapter 6 it says what what shall we say
then are we to continue in sin
so that Grace May abound you see the
same question that you just asked what
doesn't that take away people's uh you
know incentive not to sin like should
wouldn't that make them want to have
dedicated verse for that yeah literally
interesting what shall we say then are
we to continue in sin that Grace May
abound he says by no means the answer is
no of course not how can we who died to
sin still live in it so what happens is
is when you come to Christ you accept
Christ as your lord and savior you have
died to sin and now you're living in
Christ the new life now that he's given
you so he says do you not know that all
of us who have been baptized into Christ
Jesus were baptized into his death we
were buried therefore with him by
baptism into death in order that just as
Christ was raised
from the dead by the glory of the father
we too might walk in newness of
life so for we have been United with him
in his in a death like his we shall
certainly be United with him in a
resurrection like his what we know that
our old self our old self was
crucified with him in order that the
body of sin might be brought to nothing
so that we no longer are slaves of sin
for one who has died has been set free
from sin now if we have died with Christ
we believe that we also live with him we
know that Christ being raised from the
dead will never die again death no
longer has dominion over him for the
death he died he died to sin once for
all but the life he lives is to God so
you must also consider consider
yourselves so how do how do we respond
what's our mindset what's the incentive
consider yourselves dead to sin and
alive in God alive to God in Christ
Jesus so as a Christian what is my
mindset my incentive is I'm dead to sin
I that old that old life that old
mindset that old appetite that I used to
have done away with prior to converting
right yeah prior to converting uh right
so now that is done away with I'm in
Christ now living a new life so my new
my my my incentive is to live a life to
God now in Christ Jesus okay okay great
I have a question you have another
question you know how you put me yeah no
you that was great no I'm gonna that
that was great you went toate to the
source you read it out and I understood
I want to I want to test it the same way
you had me in the you held me in the
courtroom I want to see what you say
Okay I right yeah exactly I commit a
crime right yeah I commit a crime I go
outside and I punch an old lady and
knocked her unconscious and she passed
away that's what I did I go to the court
to the judge and I right there say your
honor I have a change of heart I have
realized what I've done is wrong I have
found the truth I will never commit sin
again please let me free would he is he
just for accepting my forgiveness
because I have now converted not not not
unless let me answer you not unless the
sin or the crime is paid for okay yeah
so so my friend again for in what world
should that judge not punish me for that
woman's death just because of someone
else who have dealt it for me any amount
of bail would any amount of bail get me
out of that yeah if there's a yeah
there's a bail amount on your arrest
absolutely you wait you think a monetary
value should get me out of me taking a
life of a poor woman no what I'm saying
is is that is that for certain cases
they'll put a bail amount no the C that
I'm giving is my hypothetical so there's
no bail amount on
it again do you think there's an amount
of B of of money that should get me out
of the the crime that I took a life
you're talking about a courtroom so if
you're talking about courtroom and legal
and and legalities you're talking I know
so you're talking about you're talking
about a person who's who's being
sentenced my my my position is that the
person cannot be let go unless unless
the crime is dealt with the crime has to
be dealt with somehow either by him or
by by a Somebody by
cariously wait wait so if it's it's not
just carried by him how is it Justified
what again somebody can come in and pay
the bail amount now if you're talking
about in a case where there is no bail
amount then there is no billing out
there's no way out he has to he has to
take the punishment for if you just say
yes and I accept you think that is an
amount whatever that amount of billing
is that should be sufficient for him to
be not be held uh accountable it's not
that he's not held accountable he is
held accountable it's just being it's
being handled oh she should be let free
without a punishment it's being the
punishment is the
payment well okay so that's what we
differ again I don't think that that
should be an actual way of him dealing
with his with his actions someone else
paying for his crime of what he've done
I don't think that's fair okay so if it
if somebody if somebody willfully says
wait wait no no don't don't don't take
don't take him I I I got it I I'll pay
for the whole thing I'll do it is that
is that just is just I think the
threshold of the crime should be taken
considered there are things that someone
should be able to do that that shouldn't
be a way to let him go okay and so I I I
understand what you're saying now
when it comes to when it comes to sin
against God who's the only one who can
appease for our
[Music]
sin well God yeah exactly so we're not
just talking about just anybody just
anybody anytime di can Harry
that's I just say the judge is the only
one of course that can be the one but
I'm just saying the judge to make the
choice off of someone billing him
depending on what he or she did right
like for shitler doing that or M or
murder doing that grap is doing that
these are the things that should not
just be let like again I wish I my
camera no trust me I I agree it
shouldn't be let go which is why God
comes take represent represents mankind
no it doesn't because you're missing it
again Jesus Christ took the punishment
bro he did it he was beaten bruised spit
on pierced whipped he took the
punishment bro yeah it was horrible but
then but that's what I'm saying people
again human nature stop do you get it
that in Christianity I do I get that
part I get it because you but it seems
like every time we get to the end of it
it's like all of a sudden that part
disappears from your mind not valuing it
enough okay but do you get it in
Christianity somebody took the
punishment for us it didn't just go
unscathed it got handled you
understand so in I I don't think it's an
effective way I I know that there was an
attempt under your view that it was
handled with I don't think it was an
effective way to do so is what I'm
arguing all right well I guess that's
the end of this man well you you now now
you have you know uh uh you know what we
believe you know what you know what our
is so I I would say you know consider
continue to consider it and think about
it I I definitely talk I enjoyed our
talk you helped me yeah and you helped
me to understand my question in the
beginning so I I appreciate too I I
really do but I'll I guess yeah I'll let
yeah we'll talk again soon man we'll
talk again yeah I'll request if I have
if I have different questions in mind to
see how you combat them all right man
thank you take care man